This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vidantantham. Unpredictable things happen to us all the time. Your car breaks down. The babysitter cancels. You get sick. Those little moments shift the direction of your day or your week. And then there are the bigger things in life. The earthquake kind of change that shakes everything around you,
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们总会遇到各种意料之外的事。汽车抛锚了。保姆临时有事。你生病了。这些小插曲会改变你一天或一周的走向。生活中还有更重大的事情。那种如地震般的巨变会动摇你周围的一切，
that breaks down your sense of who you are and what your life is. And in the process of getting back on your feet, you might realize that something's different. Maybe you come out of it with a new perspective, a sense of direction you never imagine. Today on the show, we have two stories of that kind of change and the transformation it brings. Oh, and we have some pretty beautiful music that comes with those stories. Derek Amato is sitting at the piano in NPR Studio 1. As you're listening to him play, you might think he's had years of musical training.
彻底打破你对自我认知以及生活的理解。而在重新振作的过程中，你可能会意识到有些事情变了。也许你因此获得了新的视角，以及从未想象过的方向感。今天节目中，我们将讲述两个关于这种巨变及随之而来的蜕变的故事。哦，这些故事还伴随着美妙动听的音乐。德里克·阿马托正坐在NPR第1号演播室的钢琴前。听着他弹奏，你可能会觉得他受过多年的音乐训练。
But Derek is unusual. He's said to have something called a quiet Savan syndrome that left him with the incredible ability to play the piano. We'll talk about what that means, but let's back up a minute. I grew up a typical kid. I was an extremely aggressive athlete.
但德里克与众不同。据说他患有一种被称为“获得性学者综合征”的病症，这赋予了他惊人的钢琴演奏能力。我们接下来会探讨这意味着什么，但让我们先倒回从前。我从小就是个普通孩子。我是一个极具侵略性的运动员。
So that was kind of my thing. I was a baseball football basketball player. You were a jock. I was a jock, yeah. I had musical interest from very early on. My grandmother was a organ player for the church. So I mean, I was around it. I remember Sunday mornings going, sitting next to her on the bench, and even though I didn't understand what she was doing or how to play the instrument, I loved to sit with her and sing. It was just
所以这就是我的特长。我是个棒球、橄榄球、篮球运动员。你是个体育生。我是个体育生，是的。我很早就对音乐产生了兴趣。我奶奶是教堂的风琴手。所以我的生活里一直都有音乐。我记得星期天早上，我坐在她身边的长凳上，尽管我不懂她在做什么，也不知道怎么弹那个乐器，但我就是喜欢挨着她坐，跟着一起唱。这只是
my comfort zone as a child when I go to church. I get to sit and watch her play the organ and sing. It was just my comfort zone as a child when I go to church. I get to sit and watch her play the organ and sing. At his mother's insistence, Derek dabbled in music. He joined the school band, played drums, tinkered around with a guitar, formed a rock band with friends, but he did not take formal lessons or get any musical training. OK, so that's the setup.
我小时候去教堂时的舒适区。我可以坐在那儿看她弹风琴、唱歌。这只是我小时候去教堂时的舒适区。我可以坐在那儿看她弹风琴、唱歌。在母亲的坚持下，德里克涉足了音乐。他加入了学校乐队，打过鼓，摆弄过吉他，和朋友组建了一支摇滚乐队，但他没有接受过正规课程或任何音乐训练。好的，这就是背景。
What happens to Derek in 2006 is both terrifying and fascinating. What happens to Derek in 2006 is both terrifying and fascinating. He was in South Dakota visiting friends and family. I got together with some friends and we were going to have a little barbecue party at the pool and indoor pool. And we were horsing around and this young man walked in. He must have been about 14, 12, 14. And he had this little miniature football with him. So of course, we started throwing the football at each other, and I thought I could just run on the side of the pool and then dive over the water and catch the football in the
德里克在2006年的遭遇既可怕又迷人。德里克在2006年的遭遇既可怕又迷人。他当时在南达科他州探望亲友。我和一些朋友聚在一起，我们打算在一个室内游泳池办一个小型的烧烤派对。我们当时在打闹，然后走进来一个年轻男孩。他大概14岁，12、14岁左右。他带着一个小型的迷你美式橄榄球。所以当然，我们开始互相扔橄榄球，然后我想我可以沿着泳池边跑，接着跳进水里，在空中接住
air. And the idea was you would catch it and then fall into the pool. Yeah, just catch it in the air and then fall into the water. So I went running on the side of the pool. And I remember, I remember running alongside the pool. I remember even diving in to catch the ball. And I knew I was diving towards a shallow end. I was very aware and I miscalculated the depth obviously
橄榄球。这个想法是你接住球，然后落入泳池中。是的，就是在空中接住它，然后落入水中。所以我开始沿着泳池边奔跑。我记得，我记得自己正沿着泳池跑。我还记得自己为了接球而跳了进去。我知道我跳向的是浅水区。我很清楚这一点，但很显然我误判了深度，
and I hit the upper left side of my face. And that's all I remember. It was like an explosion. And you know, most of us had a head trauma when we were a kid or hit our head. And it's that sickening feeling you get when it's like, oh no, I know something. I just did something extremely wrong.
然后我的左脸上方撞到了。这就是我所记得的一切。那感觉就像一场爆炸。你知道，我们大多数人在小时候都受过头部创伤或撞到过头部。那种感觉极其糟糕，就像是“噢不，我知道出事了”。我刚刚做了一件极其出格的事。
And this isn't right. And I knew I had hurt myself. Diagnosis was a massive concussion. And what was the treatment? Relax, stay quiet, lay in bed for a few days. I spent the night at the hospital the next morning they sent me home. I went home and I slept for five days basically. And then you get up and do what? We sit at the table and I said, well, I feel pretty darn good. I know I had an accident and I'm not sure what happened. And I said,
这太不对劲了。我知道自己受伤了。诊断结果是严重的脑震荡。那治疗方法是什么？放松，保持安静，卧床休息几天。我在医院过夜，第二天早上他们把我送回家。我回家后基本上睡了五天。然后你起来做什么？我们坐在桌旁，我说：“嗯，我感觉好极了。我知道我出了事故，虽然我不太确定发生了什么。”我说，
well, I'm in a pack and I think I can go back to Denver in a couple days. So I called Rick and I said, why don't you come over and get me, we'll say goodbyes and I'll be on my way in a couple of days. And so we went over to the apartment and we were just hanging out. And he had this tiny keyboard, just this little piece of junk in the corner. And it was just on the stand, dusty and not sure if it had ever been played. And I kept staring at it as we were talking. And we were just sitting talking like just like this.
“我的行李都收拾好了，我想我过两天就能回丹佛了。”所以我打电话给里克，我说：“你为什么不过来接我，我们告别一下，过两天我就要上路了。”于是我们去了公寓，大家就在那儿闲逛。他有个很小的键盘，就是角落里那种破烂货。它就放在支架上，落满了灰尘，也不知道以前有没有人弹过。我们聊天的时候，我一直盯着它看。我们当时就这么坐着聊天。
And I kept looking at it and looking at it curious. It was like not sure why I was drawn to it and I finally just walked over to it and I thought I'll just hit a few of these keys. I turn it on and see what happens. I had no clue and I sat down and my fingers just went crazy. My fingers were like somebody just... I don't know, Rick said the ghost of Beethoven jumped into my body. I don't know how else to explain it. I went crazy and just played and played. And it wasn't like I was just picking away. What did you play?
我一直看着它，带着好奇看着它。就好像我不确定自己为什么会被它吸引，最后我终于朝它走了过去，心想我只要按几个键就行了。我打开它，看看会发生什么。我毫无头绪，我坐下来，我的手指就彻底失控了。我的手指就像是有人……我不知道，里克说贝多芬的灵魂附体了。我不知道该怎么解释。我整个人都疯了似地弹个不停。而且不只是在胡乱拨弄。你弹了什么？
I played... I think it was more of a classical structure to it. And I sat there and did this for, I don't know, five, six hours without stopping. And we just, I remember looking at him and there was tears rolling out his face. I mean, he's a Christian coward, he's a pretty emotional guy. He's a sweet, sweet man. And he just, you know, he didn't know what to think as, because I mean, I'm known him since we were kids.
我弹了……我觉得它更具有古典音乐的结构。我坐在那里，就这样弹了大概五、六个小时，一刻也没有停。我们只是，我记得看着他，眼泪顺着他的脸颊流了下来。我是说，他是个基督徒，是个相当感性的人。他是个非常非常温柔的人。他只是，你知道，他不知道该作何感想，因为我是说，我们从小就认识。
And he'd never seen me play a piano, so he's like, what's going on? I'm not sure what's going on. I didn't want to stop playing because I was like, well, what if I stop and then and then this doesn't happen tomorrow morning I mean this is kind of cool. I don't I mean, it doesn't happen every day You just sit out and start playing a piano. So I think this is kind of different. Let's let's just stay here for a while It must have been two o'clock in the morning and I was exhausted. My brain was flying still is racing and So he took me back to my mother's house, we had a call the day, I was beat up.
他从来没见过我弹钢琴，所以他在想：这到底是怎么回事？我也不确定发生了什么。我不想停下来，因为我想：万一我停下来，明天早上这个能力就没了呢？这其实挺酷的。我是说，不是每天都能随随便便坐下来就开始弹钢琴的。所以我觉得这挺不寻常的。我们……我们就在这儿待一会儿吧。当时一定是凌晨两点，我精疲力竭。我的大脑还在飞速运转，依然处于亢奋状态。所以他把我送回了我母亲家，那天就这样结束了，我累垮了。
And I went to bed and the next morning I woke up and I was paranoid, I was nervous, I was scared, I was like, how am I going to tell my mother? The person that knows me best on this planet. I just hit my head and I'm a little whacked out. How am I going to tell her that I just discovered that I know how to play the piano fairly well to a person that's known me my entire life, 40 years? So I said, well, I don't know any other way than to take her to a music store.
我上床睡觉，第二天早上醒来时，我感到偏执、紧张、害怕，我想：“我该怎么告诉我母亲？这个星球上最了解我的人。我刚刚撞了脑袋，现在有点神志不清。我怎么能对一个认识了我一辈子、整整40年的人说，我刚刚发现自己挺会弹钢琴的呢？”所以我想，除了带她去乐器行，别无他法。
So I said, we had a cup of coffee and I said, it's front of the music store real quick. And she said, what do you want to buy? And I said, nothing. I said, I just want to show you something real fast. I went teller. We get to the music store. We walk in, the salesman says, I don't know, like, you know,
我说我们喝了杯咖啡，然后我说：“去前面那家乐器行一趟吧。”她说：“你想买什么？”我说：“什么都不买。我只是想让你快点看个东西。”我去找店员。我们到了乐器行。一走进去，销售员就说……我不知道，就像，
he can help you, he wants to sell me something. And I said, if you show me how to get this piano, this digital piano on, that's all I need. And then give me just 10 minutes. So he turns it on, shows me how to turn the darn thing on. I tell my mother to sit down next to me. What did you play? I don't quite remember what I played that time, but I was doing more of a...
他能帮到你，他想向我推销东西。我说：“如果你教我怎么打开这台钢琴，这台数码钢琴，这就够了。然后给我10分钟就行。”于是他打开了它，教我怎么打开那个该死的东西。我叫我母亲在我旁边坐下。你弹了什么？我不太记得当时弹了什么，但我弹得更多的是……
I wanted to sing to her for some reason because it was such an emotional thing. And I was going into like... And I just started to kind of chord this and she was looking at me like, whoa, when did this transpire? I mean, she had all kinds of questions right away. And then I just kind of went nuts and started going crazy just to show her, look at this, look at this. And she started crying, she really did say much.
出于某种原因，我想为她唱歌，因为那是一个极具情感的时刻。我开始像……我开始弹奏和弦，她看着我，眼神仿佛在说：“哇，这什么时候发生的？”我是说，她立刻有一大堆问题。然后我有点失控了，开始疯狂地弹奏，只是为了向她展示：看这个，看这个！她开始哭了，她真的没说太多话。
It was a very quiet drive home. As you're telling me this, Derek, I almost have the feeling that you are pulling my leg right now because it seems this is not possible. This is just simply not, it could not have happened. You know, well, if I would have had my way, I'm not sure if I would have ended up a piano player. I kind of wanted to be a baseball player and I were working the fighting business.
回家的车程非常安静。德里克，你跟我说这些的时候，我几乎觉得你是在拿我开涮，因为这听起来太不可能了。这简直就是，根本不可能发生。你知道的，如果由我作主的话，我还不确定自己最终会不会成为一个钢琴家。我其实更想成为一名棒球运动员，我还从事过格斗行业。
So I don't know. And you know what, I invite skepticism because I think when something so beautiful and profound happens, we have to, we have to question. At what stage did you stop questioning that you had a scale? I'm assuming that you were skeptical as well. I mean, you told me that when you went home the first night, you were afraid that it was going to be a one day scale and and was going to be gone by the next morning. At what point did you stop questioning it and say, this is actually a new skill that I
所以我不清楚。你知道吗，我欢迎持怀疑态度的人，因为我认为当如此美丽而深奥的事情发生时，我们必须，我们必须提出质疑。你是在哪个阶段停止对这种天赋产生怀疑的？我假设你一开始也是怀疑的。我是说，你告诉我第一天晚上回家时，你还担心这只是一日限定的天赋，第二天早上就会消失。你是在什么时候停止质疑，并说“这确实是我拥有的新技能”的？
have? You know, I think you kind of grow into that, getting comfortable with accepting what's transpired in your life. I definitely didn't want it to go away. In the first year or two, it was a little, you know, like I would wake up thinking, I need to get to a piano. I need to make sure it's still here. And as time went on, I started to understand that,
你知道，我觉得你是在慢慢适应的过程中接受了这一切，开始坦然接受生活中发生的变化。我绝对不想让它消失。头一两年，这种感觉还是有点……比如我醒来时会想：我得去一架钢琴前，我得确保它还在。随着时间的推移，我开始明白，
well, the doctors tell me it can go away as fast as it came. And acquired musical savants syndrome, that means you've acquired a gift. And I got to that point where I just accepted the fact that I'm going to enjoy every second of this. Because if I wake up tomorrow and it's gone, I want to be able to say that I did the best I could to display it to a society looking in at my life
医生告诉我，它来得有多快，去得也可能有多快。而获得性音乐学者综合征，意味着你获得了一份天赋。我到了那个地步，我只是接受了这个事实：我要享受其中的每一秒。因为如果我明天醒来它消失了，我希望能够说，我已经尽我所能向这个审视我生活的社会展示了这一点，
and say, I've been inspired by this, or the human potential is amazing, or the brain is just a magnificent organ that we don't know anything about. And I think it became that comfort knowing that, I'm gonna enjoy it every single second. And if it stays beautiful, if it goes away then
并告诉他们：“我受到了启发，人类的潜能是惊人的，大脑是一个我们一无所知的宏伟器官。”我想这种确知带来的慰藉就是：我会享受它的每一分每一秒。如果它一直这么美妙下去，万一它消失了，那
I guess I'll go get a job. Have you spoken to neurologist who is skeptical about what's happening to you? I think they're all skeptical the moment they walk in the door. I mean, I feel skeptical. I'm sorry, I know that you're a nice guy. You seem like a trustworthy person. Right, right, I expect you to be. But I have the feeling that you're just,
我想我就去找份工作吧。你跟对你这种遭遇持怀疑态度的神经学家谈过吗？我觉得他们一进门时都是持怀疑态度的。我是说，我觉得自己也很怀疑。对不起，我知道你是个好人。你看上去是个值得信赖的人。对，对，我本该如此。但我总觉得你只是，
this is just one big giant prank. Well, that's because I'm still, I'm articulate and I still have most of my marbles. So I can display the story in a different way than let's say the guy that hit his head and woke up a piano player, but he's not all here. If I asked you to play Twinkle, Twinkleinkle Little Star for me, could you try that? I don't think I can play it.
这只是一个巨大的恶作剧。那是因为我还算口齿伶俐，而且我的理智基本还算健全。所以我可以说出与众不同的故事，比如相比于那种撞了脑袋醒来后会弹钢琴但脑子不太好使的人，我能更好地表达自己。如果我让你为我弹一首《小星星》，你能试一下吗？我想我弹不了。
I tried to do happy birthday for a person the other day and I couldn't figure it out. No. Answers no. It's taught with C. Is that this one right here? Oh. Wait. Oh wait. Where was that first note then? Wait.
我前几天想给一个人弹《生日快乐》，结果我弹不出来。不。回答是不行。它是从C调开始的。是这个键吗？哦。等等。哦等等。那第一个音在哪里？等等。
Where it, oh. So it's all up and down. Gosh, darn it. I can see it now. I mean, that's kind of the there. Thanks for the first note, though. But it's sort of an interesting thing, isn't, which is like you don't go up, you don't see someone who says, you know, I can throw a fastball at, I don't know, 140 miles an hour, but I don't know how to reach out and shake your hand.
在哪儿，哦。所以它上下都是。天哪，该死。我现在能看出来了。我是说，这有点像……谢谢你的第一个音。但这其实是一件很有趣的事，不是吗？就像你不会看到有人说：“你知道，我可以投出时速140英里的快球，但我不知道怎么伸手跟你握手。”
And to me, your displaying musical ability at one end of the spectrum, whereas playing Twinkle Twinkle Little Star, I can do that. And you find it hard, and I find it just really difficult to understand how you can be so good at the extreme end without knowing the basics. I'm right there with you.
对我来说，你在一个极端展现出了音乐才华，而弹奏《小星星》这种事，我能做到，但你却觉得很难，我真的很难理解，一个人怎么能在缺乏基础的情况下，在极端的一端做得如此出色。我和你有同感。
I'm on your side. I'm fascinated with that too. Does it disturb you? Does it worry you that you have this ability? No, I mean I'm a Christian kid, so I think I think this is what God wants me. I think this has already been penned out my story. I How else I mean I have to live with this every day, so if I sit and beat my own mind up about, is this nature versus nurture and nature and all this nonsense?
我站在你这边。我也对此着迷。这会让你感到困扰吗？你拥有这种能力，这会让你担心吗？不，我是说我是一个信仰基督教的孩子，所以我想……我认为这是上帝对我的安排。我觉得我的故事早就被写好了。不然还能怎样？我是说我每天都得带着这个生活，所以如果我坐在这里折磨自己的大脑，去想这是先天还是后育，是先天论还是后天论这些废话，
But I mean, I've talked to the best doctors, the smart doctors, and the planet. And they all got a different little input. And they all got something different to say about it. Most all of them are skeptic when I walk in. And most all of them when I walk out are right here with me. Have any of them suggested treatments? Yes, yes.
但这真的……我和最好的医生、地球上最聪明的医生谈过。他们每个人都有一点不同的看法。他们每个人对这件事都有不同的说法。我进去的时候，他们大多数人都持怀疑态度；而我走出来的时候，他们大多数人都跟我站在了一边。他们之中有人建议过治疗吗？有，有的。
The Dr. Reeves at the Mayo Clinic when I was filming with the Discovery Channel, he was fascinated with this as well. And he said, the best way to fair him to explain is like a roller coaster. If you get on a roller coaster that doesn't stop, sooner or later it's going to get tiring. So maybe we suggest slowing down the stimulant,
我在和探索频道拍摄时，妙佑医疗国际的里夫斯医生也对此非常着迷。他说，最好的解释方式就像是坐过山车。如果你坐上一辆不停下来的过山车，迟早你会感到疲惫。所以也许我们建议减缓兴奋剂的作用，
the overstimulated brain, you're firing these neurons at a pace that's unheard of. So let's try some. Seize your medication to shut those down, right? I don't know understand how it works, but I do know it slows down the firing of the neurons. Why would I want to take synthetic drugs and mask something possibly that I'm enjoying to the point where I don't want it to slow down and go away. I'll take the hyperness and the ADHD and OCD and all that garbage that comes
让过度刺激的大脑慢下来，你神经元放电的速度是前所未闻的。所以让我们试试。用药物来关闭那些神经元，对吗？我不太懂它是怎么运作的，但我确实知道它能减缓神经元的放电。我为什么要服用合成药物去掩盖某种我正在享受的事物呢？我不想让它慢下来并最终消失。我可以接受亢奋、多动症、强迫症以及所有伴随而来的垃圾。
with this maybe. What if it has a consequence where you are burning your brain at a level that is not healthy for you. I mean, so for example, let's... Then I guess I go down on fire, baby. And that's how the story ends, and I'm good with that. You're still the guy who would die for the swoop football of the swimming pool. Yeah.
如果它带来的后果是你的大脑在以一种对你不健康的程度在超负荷运转呢？我是说，举个例子……那我想我就在烈火中燃烧吧，宝贝。故事就这样结束了，我对此挺满意的。你还是那个愿意为了游泳池里的橄榄球去赴汤蹈火的人。是的。
Of course, Derek Amato isn't the only person with a quads of Ancindro. Others have experienced the profound changes that come with this condition. They are so motivated, they are in love with what they're doing. It's almost like an extension of who they are. Also, I'm going to challenge Derek to play the studio wall. I see on this wall, I see these squares. Some of them have different depths, so the full squares almost feel like a whole note to me. Keep listening, it'll make more sense soon. I'm Shankar Vedantam and you're listening to Hidden Brain from NPR. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This week on the show, we're looking at the specific moments people lose something big
当然，德里克·阿马托并不是唯一一个患有获得性学者综合征的人。其他人也经历过这种病症带来的深远变化。他们如此充满动力，他们热爱自己所做的事。这几乎就像是他们自我的一种延伸。此外，我要挑战德里克去弹奏演播室的墙壁。我看到这面墙上有一些方块。其中一些有不同的深度，所以这些饱满的方块对我来说几乎就像是一个全音符。继续听下去，很快就会更好理解。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，您收听的是来自NPR的《隐藏的大脑》。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。本周节目中，我们关注的是人们失去重大事物的特定时刻，
and how that change can point them in new directions. Before the break, Derrick Amato told us a story of how he became a musician after a head injury. Before the accident, he couldn't play the piano. But after, his musical talent was just undeniable. If this is the first time you're hearing our show, I have a confession to make. I'm a card-carrying rationalist. When surprising things happen, I don't call them miracles.
以及这种改变如何为他们指明新的方向。在休息之前，德里克·阿马托向我们讲述了他在头部受伤后如何成为一名音乐家的故事。在事故发生之前，他不会弹钢琴。但事故发生后，他的音乐才华不容置疑。如果这是你第一次收听我们的节目，我得坦白一件事。我是一个纯粹的理性主义者。当令人惊奇的事情发生时，我不会称它们为奇迹。
I look for explanations. Derrick's very charming, his story's amazing, but I found myself asking over and over how something like this could happen. That's when I came by a couple of researchers who've spent years studying people who've suddenly acquired savant-like gifts. Darrell Treffert is a psychiatrist in Wisconsin. He studied Derek. And I must say that in his case, I am, you know, was a sturdle as you
我在寻找解释。德里克非常迷人，他的故事令人惊叹，但我发现自己不断地在问，这样的事情怎么可能会发生。就在那时，我遇到了一对研究人员，他们花了多年时间研究那些突然获得类学者天赋的人。达勒姆·特雷弗特是威斯康星州的一位精神病学家。他研究过德里克。我必须说，在他的案例中，我和你一样，
about the fact that he went to the piano and knew where to place his fingers and so forth. The reason that I'm inclined to accept that is because I've seen that in some of these other cases although probably not quite as abrupt as he but and to me at least that having seen a lot of sub-hands when I see some of these acquired sub-hands cases it is really quite jarring. I don't know if you remember what Derek said about his injury. He leaped across the swimming pool for the football, and when he came down hard, he heard what sounded like an explosion.
对径直走到钢琴前就知道手指该放在哪里等等表现感到震惊。我之所以倾向于接受这一点，是因为我在其他一些案例中也看到过这种情况，尽管可能没有他那么突然，但对我来说，至少在见过许多学者综合征患者之后，看到这些获得性学者综合征案例时，真的相当震撼。我不知道你是否还记得德里克关于他受伤的描述。他为了接橄榄球跃过泳池，当他重重落下时，他听到了一声类似于爆炸的声音。
And I miscalculated the depth, obviously, and I hit the upper left side of my face. The left side of his face. That's an important clue. In general, in Savonsen Room itself, whether congenital or acquired, there tends to be a more left brain injury with right brain compensation and the right brain areas or ability that seem to emerge have to do with art music and mathematics, actually. Art, music, and math. All skills that involve pattern recognition. At the University of Pennsylvania, cognitive psychologist Scott Barry Kaufman said, think about it. These are the skills you might imagine are built into the architecture of the brain.
很显然我误判了深度，然后我的左脸上方撞到了。他的左脸。这是一个重要的线索。总的来说，无论是先天还是后天获得的学者综合征本身，往往都伴随着更多的左脑损伤和右脑代偿，而那些似乎浮现出来的右脑区域或能力，实际上与艺术、音乐和数学有关。艺术、音乐和数学。所有这些技能都涉及模式识别。宾夕法尼亚大学的认知心理学家斯科特·巴里·考夫曼说，想想看。这些技能可能就是你想象中内置于大脑结构中的能力。
In other words, we might come hardwired for certain kinds of activities. This is the insight that helped me see that Derek might not be pulling a prank. Most of us, in fact, effortlessly learn things. Just like Derek says, he never took classes to learn piano, you probably didn't take formal lessons to learn your first language. The truth is that a lot of things we learn in life were not done deliberately. When we were very young and the teachers of 2 and 4 we learned a huge amount of new words and learned the grammatical structure of our language automatically without we didn't
换句话说，我们可能对某些类型的活动有着天生的硬连线。正是这种洞察力帮助我认识到德里克可能不是在搞恶作剧。事实上，我们大多数人都能毫不费力地学习事物。就像德里克所说，他从未上过学习钢琴的课，你大概也没有参加过正式的课程来学习你的第一门语言。事实是，我们在生活中学习的很多东西都不是刻意完成的。在我们很小的时候，大约2岁和4岁的老师（时期），我们自动地学习了大量的生词和语言的语法结构，我们并没有
sit down when we were 2 years old and say, right, I'm'm gonna learn all the grammatical syntax and what it all means and so we have these structures that help us learn if you look at it this way most people have skills that might seem Savant like to a visitor from another planet we learn these skills effortlessly in fact It doesn't even feel like learning it feels like fun What makes Savants unique in other words is not that their brains do amazing things. All brains do amazing things. What's different is that they're demonstrating effortless learning in domains that usually call for sustained effort. Now I'm not going to tell you you should go out and bang your head against the floor
在2岁时坐下来说：“好吧，我要学习所有的语法句法以及它背后的含义。”所以我们拥有这些帮助我们学习的结构。如果你这样看的话，对于一个来自外星球的访客来说，大多数人都具备看起来像是学者般的技能。我们毫不费力地学习这些技能，事实上，这甚至不像是学习，感觉就像是在玩耍。换句话说，学者们的独特之处不在于他们的大脑能做惊人的事情。所有的大脑都能做惊人的事情。不同之处在于，他们在那些通常需要持续努力的领域表现出了毫不费力的学习能力。现在我不是在告诉你们应该去用头撞泳池底来学习弹钢琴。绝大多数脑震荡都不会催生出一个内在的天才，它们的后果往往极其糟糕。但德里克的故事确实向我们——甚至向我这个坚定的理性主义者——表明，我们的内心拥有未曾意识到的世界和天赋。当我看着这些学者时，我认为其核心为人类提供了巨大启示的是，他们充满了动力，他们热爱自己所做的事。这几乎就像是他们自我的一种延伸。对我来说，这带来了极大的希望，
of a swimming pool to learn to play the piano. The vast majority of concussions don't produce an inner genius, they have terrible outcomes. But Derek's story does suggest, even to this card carrying rationalist, that we have worlds within us, gifts, that we do not realize that we possess. When I look at these savants, what I see at the core that I think is, offers a lot of inspiration to humanity, is that they are so motivated, they are in love with what they're doing. It's almost like an extension of who they are. To me, that offers a lot of hope,
或者激励着我们，也许我们所有人都能找到那个真正让我们能够放声歌唱的载体。当德里克在NPR第1号演播室弹奏钢琴时，我注意到他身后有一面墙。那是隔音墙，上面有中空的木质立方体，每个立方体的深度都不同。德里克曾告诉我，当他弹奏时，他看到方块从他身边漂过。
or inspires me that perhaps all of us can find that vehicle that really allows us to sing. As Derek was playing the piano in NPR studio one, I noticed there was a wall behind him. It had soundproofing, hollow wooden cubes, each of a different depth. Derek had told me that when he plays, he sees squares floating by him.
所以我请他转过身去，看着墙壁，告诉他看到了什么。我看到这面墙上有一些方块。其中一些有不同的深度。所以这些饱满的方块对我来说几乎就像是一个全音符。我请德里克为我弹奏这面墙。因为这些深度，我看到了低音。你看到那些被完全填满的暗色方块了吗？
So I asked him to turn around, look at the wall, and tell me what he saw. I see on this wall, I see these squares. Some of them have different depths. So the full squares almost feel like a whole note to me. I ask Derek to play the wall for me. I see low notes because of all the depth. You see the dark ones that are filled in all the way?
它们很显眼，所以我看到了低音，比如……现在我来到了中间的方格。看我现在在那些中间方格里的位置，所以那些是……那是完全不同的……现在我们要进入一个完全不同的领域了。我现在开始兴奋了。还有别的墙可以看吗？看那个。所以你刚刚是在弹奏这面墙？你刚才弹的就是这个。
They stand out, so I see low notes like... Now I'm in the middle boxes. See where I'm at now in those middle boxes, so those are... And that's a whole different... Now we're getting into a whole different thing. Now I'm getting excited. Got any more walls with the look at that. So you were just playing the wall? That's what you were playing with.
我在弹我所感受到的。我在弹我所感受到的。所以我从这里开始。好吧，想象一下那是乐谱小节。所以我弹了上面的那个。我再弹一次。我会完全精确地按照我在这里看到的方式来弹。然后它变到了这个小节，我们现在移到下方了，现在我们要移到下一个乐谱小节，我看到了。
I was playing what I was. I was playing what I was. So I started here. Okay, so imagine that's the music bar. So I played the top one. I'll do it again. I'll do it precisely exactly like I started here. Okay, so imagine that's the music bar. Yeah. So I played the top one, I'll do it again. I'll do it precisely exactly like I saw it. And then it changes to this bar, we've moved down now now and now we're going to move down to the next bar of music and I see.
然后我们再回到顶部，然后我们可以来一段爵士乐。而且，我是说它就这样没完没了地继续下去，这些墙可能很危险，因为如果我家里有这样的墙，我可能根本不想睡觉了。你是说你这辈子从来没有弹过刚刚为我弹奏的这段音乐吗？没有。第三排甚至可能是完全不同的另一首曲子。
And then we'll go back up to the top and then we can make a jazz. And that's, and I mean it just goes on and on and on and on and on and these walls could be dangerous because I wouldn't want to sleep at all. If I had walls like this in my house. Are you telling me that you have never played the piece of music you just played for me in your life before? No. And this third row might even be a whole different composition.
这就是我要说的。那些方块的深度、中间的那些排以及中间的那些圆圈，对我来说就是这些。对我来说，那就是流动的图案。然后顶部那些厚实的方块，那就是我看到它的地方。它就这样瞬间发生了变化。然后我移到了下一个，那是完全不同的流动感。
That's what I'm saying. The depths of those blocks, those middle rows and those circles in the middle, that's what these are to me. That's what those are rolling patterns to me. And then those chunky ones on the top, that's where I see that. And it just changes like that, suddenly. And then I moved out of the next one and it's a whole different flow.
那是音乐家德里克·阿马托，他在意外撞击头部后获得了钢琴技能。对德里克来说，当他获得惊人的天赋时，一切都改变了。他的人生现在指向了一个激动人心的全新音乐方向。但有时候，最宝贵的时刻反而是某些东西被从你身边夺走的时候。在那些时刻，你可以看到一种不同类型的成长，从减法中成长，在失去中重获新生。我真的对失去自己全身心热爱、充满激情并构成了我生命和自我认同如此大一部分的东西感到心碎。你知道的，我首先是一名小提琴手。这是玛雅·尚卡尔，在某个重要时刻，她的人生彻底改变了。我的奶奶是一位印度古典小提琴手，所以我的妈妈在我们的阁楼里留了她的一把旧小提琴，
That was musician Derek Amado, who acquired his piano skills after accidentally hitting his head. For Derek, everything changed when he gained an incredible talent. His life now points in an exciting new musical direction. But sometimes, the most valuable moments are when some things take away from you. In those times, you can see a different kind of growth, growth from subtraction, renewal from loss. I was really devastated to lose something that I was completely in love with and so passionate about and that had really constituted such a large part of my life and my identity. You know, I was first and foremost a violinist. This is Maya Shankar, in one important moment her whole life changed. My grandmother was an Indian classical violinist and so my mom had her old violin and
放了很多年。玛雅的故事始于康涅狄格州的一个阁楼，最终将她带到了奥巴马时期的白宫。不过稍后细说。我的三个哥哥姐姐都拒绝了小提琴，说它不够酷。我妈妈最终把这把乐器交给了我，我立刻就被这件乐器的触感吸引了。我是说木头和琴弓。
our attic for many years. Maya's story begins in an attic in Connecticut and eventually brought her to the Obama White House. But more on that later. Each of my three older siblings had rejected the violin saying that it wasn't cool enough. And my mom finally gave me the instrument and I was immediately taken kind of by the tactile sensation of the instrument. I mean the wood and the bow.
我就是喜欢拉小提琴的感觉。玛雅的母亲对西方古典音乐并不太了解，但她用铃木教学法为女儿报了小提琴课。教学的重点是通过听觉演奏并发出美妙的声音。玛雅不断地练习。我在学校有一个特殊的日程安排，把所有的课都挤在一起，这样我可以稍微早一点放学，多出一点时间练习，特别是考虑到各种出行，大多数时间都完全用来练习音乐了。
I just loved the feeling of playing the violin. Maya's mother didn't know much about western classical music, but she signed up her daughter for lessons using the Suzuki method. The focus was on playing by ear and making beautiful sound. Maya practiced constantly. I had a special scheduled school to lump all my classes together so that I come a little bit early and get a little bit more practice in, and especially with all the traveling, most days were devoted exclusively to music.
她进步很快，非常快。现在，她的音乐教育中所缺少的部分是正规训练。她不太会看谱，但她有着敏锐的音乐耳朵和雄心壮志。为了找到一位能带她进入更高水平的老师，玛雅的母亲做了一件非常大胆的事。是的，所以我的妈妈，在我的小提琴生涯上她真的是个行动派，因为正如我所说，她对音乐界其实没有什么经验或接触，为了寻找机会，她不得不进行创新。有一天在纽约，靠近朱莉亚音乐学院——世界上最著名、最独家音乐机构之一的时候，我妈妈萌生了一个想法，她说：“我们为什么不去朱莉亚音乐学院看看呢？我是说，为什么不呢？”
She got good, very good. Now the part of her musical education that was missing was the formal part. She didn't know how to read music very well, but she had a fine ear, and she had ambition. In the pursuit to find a teacher who would take her to the next level, Maya's mother did something quite daring. Yeah, so my mom, she was really a go-getter when it came to my violin life because, like I said, she didn't really have a lot of experience or exposure to the music community and kind of had to innovate in order to find opportunities. There were a New York one day close to the Julia Art School, one of the world's most famous and exclusive music institutions, when her mother came up with an idea, she said, Why don't we just go to Juilliard? I mean, why not?
对吧，我们有什么好失去的？直接走进去。我们就这样走进去。所以我们走进了大楼，非常巧合的是，我们在电梯里遇到了一位学生，他师从一位音乐老师，我妈妈在电梯里和那个家庭交谈，并说：“你介意在你们上完课后，留出大约五到十分钟让玛雅为你的老师演奏一下吗？”他们非常大方，说：“当然，没问题。”
Right, what can we lose? Just walk in the door. We just walked in. So we walked into the building and just by happenstance, we happened to run into a student in the elevator who studied with a music teacher and my mom talked to that family and the elevator and said, would you mind if we just had about five or ten minutes at the end of your lesson where Maya could play for your teacher? And they were really gracious and they said, sure, no problem.
当然，你知道接下来发生了什么。玛雅为那位其他学生的音乐老师演奏了，惊艳了老师，并被一个暑期项目录取。不久之后，她就在朱莉亚音乐学院上课了。她与其他有才华的音乐家一起演奏。她甚至还登上了NPR节目。现在加入我们的是朱莉亚预科小提琴四重奏。他们是来自康涅狄格州格拉斯顿伯里的17岁女孩埃米莉·热德龙。来自康涅狄格州柴郡的15岁女孩玛雅·尚卡尔。
Of course, you know what happened next. Maya played for the other students' music teacher, wowed the teacher, and got accepted into a summer program. Soon she was taking classes at Juilliard. She was playing with other talented musicians. She was even being featured on NPR. Joining us now is the Juilliard Pre-College Violin Quartet. They are 17-year-old Emily Gendron from Glastonbury, Connecticut. 15-year-old Maya Shankar from Cheshire, Connecticut.
顺便说一句，玛雅是NPR《From the Top》节目的老兵了。她从50年代初就开始和我们在一起了。笑声 那是玛雅在NPR《From the Top》节目中的表现。她找到了自己的古典音乐归宿。她很有才华，工作努力，她面前的道路似乎一片光明。我真的很想成为一名小提琴手。
Maya, by the way, is a from-the-top veteran. She's been with us since the early 50s. LAUGHTER That was Maya on NPR's From-the-Top. She had found her classical music home. She was talented, hard-working, and the path before her seemed clear. I really wanted to be a violinist.
我对此充满了激情。每当我进行表演时，我都感到前所未有的舒适。出于某种原因，那就是我体验到心流状态的地方。那种能够花大量时间练习并试图完善艺术的能力，然后你走上舞台，某种程度上你只是全然交托。你发挥出自己最好的水平。这个过程有一种美丽而优雅的特质，我对不断涌现的机会感到无比兴奋。有一天，她在朱莉亚音乐学院的老师安排她为一位著名小提琴手演奏，一位非常著名的小提琴手。
I was so passionate about it. I never felt more comfortable than when I was performing. For some reason, that's where I experienced flow. And the ability to spend a lot of time practicing and trying to perfect the art, and then you go on stage and you kind of just surrender. You play to the best of your abilities. There's just something beautiful and elegant about that process, and I enthusiastic that opportunities kept presenting themselves. One day her teacher at Juliet arranged for her to play for a famous violinist, a very famous violinist.
我差点从座位上滑下来，因为没有哪个理智的音乐家会认为自己有机会见到伊扎克·帕尔曼，更不用说为他演奏了。你还记得你当时弹的是什么吗？我演奏了巴伯的小提琴协奏曲，我拉了第一乐章。伊扎克·帕尔曼决定收她为学生。除了星期六，我一周内还要去纽约好几次，要么去他在曼哈顿家中的工作室上课，要么去上私教课或室内乐课，到了那个时候，我非常清楚地知道，我想成为一名音乐会小提琴家。嗯，我记得她的演奏听起来……
I nearly fell over in my seat because no reasonable musician thinks they're going to get the opportunity to meet its octoprole and let alone play for its octoprole. Do you remember what you played? I played the Barber violin concert, I played the first movement. It's so apparelment decided to take her on as a student. In addition to Saturdays, I was also going to New York multiple times during the week, either for studio classes at his home in Manhattan or for private lessons or chamber music lessons And at that point it was very clear to me that I wanted to become a concert violinist Well, I remember that she sounded...
她有一种非常可爱的音乐表达方式，对我来说，这是最重要的。对于音乐会小提琴家伊扎克·帕尔曼来说，玛雅是通过听力而不是识谱来学习音乐，这是可以接受的。技术方面的东西很重要，但它们是可以学习的。你知道的，对我来说，拥有一个具有音乐感的人更重要。比方说，技巧方面，你知道的，你必须要练习技巧，但最重要的是音乐性。我觉得她在分句等方面有一种非常可爱的处理方式，
She had a very lovely way of making music and that's for me, it was the most important thing To concert violinist Itzag Pearlman, it was okay that Maya had learned to play music by ear rather than by reading music. The technical stuff was important, but it could be learned. You know, it's more important for me to have somebody musical. And let's say that the technique wise has, you know, you have to work on the technique, but the important thing is the music. And I felt that she had a very lovely way of phrasing and so on and so forth.
所以我们在这方面进行了练习，但我们也探讨了如何在技术上完成某些事情。例如，在巴伯协奏曲中，末乐章有点棘手。那么你该如何练习呢。但伊扎克·帕尔曼不仅教玛雅如何拉小提琴，他还教了她更重要的东西。如何教自己拉小提琴。我记得有很多次课，他不是直接告诉我：“玛雅，听着，很显然你对那个乐句不满意。你应该这样做来让它变得更好。”
And so we worked on that, but then we also worked on how do you accomplish technically certain things. For example, in the Barber Concert, a little lost movement is a little bit tricky. So how do you practice that. But its'ak pyramid didn't just teach Maya how to play the violin, he taught her something much more important. How to teach herself to play the violin. I remember lots of lessons were instead of telling me, Maya my okay, clearly you're unsatisfied with that phrase. Here's what you should do to make it better.
相反，他会说：“玛雅，很显然你对那个乐句不满意，你认为为了让那个乐句更好，你应该做些什么？我们来讨论一下。让我听听你对这个音乐乐句走向的期望是什么。你有什么可以利用的工具，无论是你的琴弓手臂、揉弦还是音色，来让它变得优美？”这真的很让人沮丧。我是说当时你在想：“好吧，听着，你是这里的专家。你知道的吗？”
He would instead say, my clearly you're unsatisfied with that phrase, what do you think you should do in order to make that phrase better? Let's talk about it. Let me hear what your aspirations are for the arc of this musical phrase. What tools do you have at your disposal, either with your bow arm or your vibrato or your tone in order to make it beautiful and it's really frustrating. I mean in the moment you're thinking, okay man, you're the expert here. You know?
直接告诉我该怎么做。求求你直接告诉我该怎么做，让咱们俩都省省心吧。所以你越是学会为自己思考并尝试自己解决问题，对你未来的发展就越好。一切都进展得如此顺利。玛雅15岁时，在伊扎克·帕尔曼举办的一个训练营里练习。当时我正在演奏一段极具挑战性的帕格尼尼随想曲中的片段。我只是在一个音符上过度拉伸了我的手指，然后我感觉到了一种“啵”的声音。
Just tell me what to do. Please just tell me what to do and make this easier for both of us. So the more you learn to think for yourself and to try and solve problems on your own, the better it is for you for the future. It was all going so well. When Maya was 15, she was practicing at a program run by its sock prolement. And I was playing a passage from a very challenging Paganini Caprice. And I simply overstretched my finger on one note and I felt a kind of a popping.
所以我拉伤了肌腱，它并没有像预期那样真正愈合。那你接下来的几个月是怎么度过的？你做了什么？哦，帕尔曼先生真的是个大好人，因为我的左手受伤了。他继续教我小提琴，只是用我的右手琴弓。所以在一年多的时间里，
And so I overstretched the tendon and it didn't really heal as expected. And so how did you spend the next months? What did you do? Well, Mr. Prolman was such a gem because I had injured my left hand. He continued to teach me violin just with my bow arm. So for over a year,
我去找他，我们就专注于完善我的右手琴弓，每节课我都在练习空弦，他会教我如何发出美妙的声音。你知道的，你总会觉得，你知道的，情况会解决的，所以通常发生的情况是，如果一只手特别地，你知道的，没有反应或者别的什么，你就去练习另一双手，你知道的，不要浪费时间，就去做，如果你的左手有问题，那么你就练习右手，反之亦然。你还记得玛雅在面对这种情况时的态度吗？
I went to him and we just worked on perfecting my bow arm and I would just play open strings in every lesson and he would teach me about how to produce a beautiful sound. You know, you always feel that it will know, it will resolve itself, so usually what happens if one hand doesn't particularly, you know, respond or anything like this, you work on the other hand just, you know, not to waste time just to do so if you've got your left hand that's a problem, then you work on the right hand and vice versa. Do you remember anything from Maya's attitude as she was dealing with this?
作为一名学生。你知道，她的态度很明显，她并不……我是说，我确信她当时感觉挺好的，但绝不是那种“这有什么用”的态度。玛雅的手没有康复。医生最终告诉她，她必须彻底停止演奏。我真的对失去自己全身心热爱、充满激情并构成了我生命和自我认同如此大一部分的东西感到心碎。你知道的，我首先是一名小提琴手。所以我感到焦虑，因为我担心自己再也找不到一件
As a student. You know, her attitude was obviously she wasn't, I mean, I'm sure that she was feeling good about it, but it was never like what's the use. Maya's hand didn't heal. Doctors finally told her she had to stop playing completely. I was really devastated to lose something that I was completely in love with and so passionate about and that had really constituted such a large part of my life and my identity. You know, I was first and foremost a violinist. And so I was anxious because I was worried that I would never find something
能像音乐那样让我充满激情的事物了。就这样，玛雅成为音乐会小提琴家的梦想破灭了。夏天回到康涅狄格州的家中，她开始问自己该如何收拾破碎的心，她还能找到任何像小提琴那样带给她快乐的东西吗？我们发现大学入学率上升了9%。因为发送了8条短信。我是说，这真的很深刻。8条短信正是我在任何普通日子里发给我最好的朋友的数量。
that I felt as passionately about as I did with music. Just like that, Maya's dream to become a concert violinist was over. Back home for the summer in Connecticut, she started to ask herself how she could pick up the pieces, would she ever find anything that could make her as happy as the violin? What we found was a 9% increase in college enrollment rates. As a result of 8 text messages. I mean, that is really profound. 8 text messages is what I send my best friend on any given day.
我对音乐的那种充满激情的感受。就这样，玛雅成为音乐会小提琴手的梦想破灭了。回到康涅狄格州过暑假时，她开始问自己如何收拾残局，她是否还能找到能像小提琴一样让她快乐的东西？我们发现大学入学率提高了 9%。仅仅通过 8 条短信。我的意思是，这真的很深奥。8条短信就是我任何一天发给我最好的朋友的短信。
To find out what Maya did, stay with us. I'm Shankar Vedantam and you're listening to Hidden Brain from NPR. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This week we're looking at loss and renewal, with zeroing in on the unexpected moments in life that shift our trajectories. Before the break, a young violinist named Maya Shankar learned that she could no longer play her instrument because of an injury in her left hand. Up until this point, her whole life had revolved around music. Not knowing what else to do,
要想知道玛雅做了什么，请继续收听。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，您收听的是NPR的《隐藏的大脑》。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。本周我们探讨的是失落与重生，聚焦于生活中那些改变我们人生轨迹的意外时刻。在休息之前，一位名叫玛雅·尚卡尔的年轻小提琴手得知，由于左手受伤，她再也不能演奏乐器了。在此之前，她的人生一直围绕着音乐旋转。不知还能做些什么，
Maya retreated to her parents' home in Connecticut. Her life felt in disarray. The summer before, doctors basically told me I had to stop playing completely. And just by luck, I was helping my parents clean their basement and chest her Connecticut, and I stumbled upon an old course book of my sister's, it was called The Language Instinct by Stephen Pinker.
玛雅退回了父母位于康涅狄格州的家中。她的生活陷入了一片混乱。前一个夏天，医生基本上告诉她必须完全停止演奏。纯属偶然，我当时正在帮父母清理康涅狄格州的地下室和衣柜，无意中翻到了一本我姐姐的旧课程书，书名叫斯蒂芬·平克的《语言本能》。
My I started reading, and the more she read, the more excited she became. It was remarkable for me to learn about just how complex our minds were and just what was required in order for us to have our day-to-day experiences. And so it really wet my appetite for learning more about the mind and for exploring and more depth, kind of the brilliance of the brain. She started to study cognitive science. She went on to get her PhD at Oxford on a Rhodes scholarship. She got a postdoctoral fellowship, a promising career in academia lay ahead of her. But here again, came another unexpected turn. So over Thanksgiving break of the final year of my post-doc, I was at home and I was visiting my undergraduate advisor from college, named Laurie Santos, and she was telling me about
我开始阅读，读得越多，她就越兴奋。了解我们的思维究竟有多么复杂，以及为了拥有日复一日的体验究竟需要什么，这对我来说非常了不起。因此，这确实激起了我更多了解思维、更深入探索大脑之美的好奇心。她开始研究认知科学。她以罗德奖学金前往牛津大学攻读博士学位。她获得了博士后奖学金，学术界有一段前途无量的职业生涯在等着她。但就在这里，又迎来了另一个意想不到的转折。因此，在我博士后最后一年的感恩节假期，我在家拜访了我在大学时的本科导师，名叫劳里·桑托斯，她跟我谈论了
the U.S. Department of Agriculture's efforts to get free and reduced price lunches, school lunches, into the hands of more eligible students. Students were going hungry because the process of getting certified for the lunch program was cumbersome. The Department of Agriculture came up with a simple idea. Instead of having a multi-step sign-up system, states could use information they already had about poor families to help enroll children
美国农业部为将免费和减价午餐、学校午餐送到更多符合条件的学生的努力。由于获得午餐计划认证的过程繁琐，学生们一直在挨饿。农业部想出了一个简单的想法。各州不用采取多步骤的注册系统，而是可以使用他们已经掌握的关于贫困家庭的信息来帮助登记儿童
in the lunch program. And it's just a matter of data matching and cross-enrolling these students. But as a result of this common sense reform, you know, 12.4 million students, as of 2015, were automatically enrolled into the school lunch program and had access to lunches
参加午餐计划。这只是一个数据匹配和跨期注册这些学生的问题。但由于这项通情达理的改革，你知道，截至2015年，有1240万名学生被自动纳入学校午餐计划，并能够获得午餐
and were able to thrive at school. And I remember being so moved by this example. Dumbaya, it was magical. It was just like a light bulb went off in my head, and I thought, okay, this is what I need to be doing with my life. I want to be taking research insights from the behavioral sciences and allowing them to find their way into public policy so that they can be in the service of Americans and people around the world.
并能够在学校茁壮成长。我记得被这个例子深深打动了。对玛雅来说，这太神奇了。就像我的脑海里亮起了一盏灯，我想，好吧，这就是我一生应该做的事情。我想把来自行为科学的研究见解融入公共政策，让它们为美国人以及世界各地的人们服务。
So how do you break into the world of policy when you're just a lowly postdoc? Maya knew nothing of politics. She didn't have connections in the world of government. But she did remember a lesson her mother had taught her standing outside the Julia at school years earlier. She tracked down an email address for Thomas Kalea, who was helping the Obama administration with its science policy. I sent Tom again a cold email. This is the Juilliard method again. This is my mom's Juilliard. I have to give her full credit for this. She is totally fearless and kind of inspired this trait. And I went over to his home and he asked me to pitch to him ideas
那么，当你只是一个卑微的博士后时，如何闯入政策世界呢？玛雅对政治一无所知。她在政府世界里没有任何人脉。但她确实记得她母亲多年前在茱莉亚学校外面站着时教给她的一个教训。她找到了托马斯·卡利的电子邮件地址，他当时正在协助奥巴马政府制定科学政策。我又给汤姆发了一封冷邮件。这又是茱莉亚方法。这是我妈妈的茱莉亚方法。我必须为此给她全满分。她完全无所畏惧，某种程度上启发了这种特质。我去了他家，他让我向他推销
that I had around interventions where behavioral science could improve public policy outcomes. What are you telling him? I talked to him about a number of things like the importance of using social norms to motivate behavior. So, we know from research that if you tell people that their neighbors use less energy than they do, right, they people that their neighbors use less energy than they do, they're more likely to use less energy. And there's a lot of domains in which just telling people what the data shows about people's
我围绕行为科学可以改善公共政策结果的干预措施的想法。你在跟他说什么？我和他谈了很多事情，比如利用社会规范来激励行为的重要性。所以，我们从研究中知道，如果你告诉人们他们的邻居使用的能源比他们少，对吧，人们他们的邻居使用的能源比他们少，他们更有可能使用更少的能源。在许多领域，仅仅告诉人们数据显示了人们的
actions and decisions can actually drive actions that are more in alignment with people's long-term goals or with policy objectives. And something that struck me about that conversation is I had been talking for years with my academic colleagues about the potential applications of using behavioral insights to improve people's lives. And this was the first time that when I told him an idea that I had, his response was, oh, we can find a way to do that. When I interviewed Maya in the fall of 2015, President Obama had just signed an executive order announcing that the White House was going to build behavioral insights into policy. Maya became senior adviser for the social and behavioral sciences at the White House,
行动和决策实际上可以推动更符合人们长期目标或政策目标的行动。那次对话中让我印象深刻的一件事是，我和我的学术同事们谈论了多年关于利用行为见解改善人们生活的潜在应用。这是我第一次把我的想法告诉他时，他的回应是，哦，我们可以找到办法做到这一点。2015年秋天我采访玛雅时，奥巴马总统刚刚签署了一项行政命令，宣布白宫将在政策中建立行为见解。玛雅成为白宫社会与行为科学高级顾问，
and in her new role, she was able to work on SNAP, the school lunch project that had initially so inspired her. I asked her to explain what they were working on. So we have been working with the U.S. Department of Agriculture and also local school districts to redesign communications that they're sending to families to help promote the verification process so that their kids can stay on the benefit. So we've done a few things. So there's a few behavioral insights that we've used. One is we've taken a very long list of action steps
在她的新职位上，她能够参与SNAP，即最初对她启发极大的学校午餐项目。我请她解释他们在做什么。因此，我们一直在与美国农业部以及地方学区合作，重新设计他们发送给家庭的通信，以帮助推广验证过程，以便他们的孩子可以继续获得福利。所以我们做了一些事情。因此，我们使用了一些行为见解。一是我们将一长串行动步骤
required for verification and condense them into three easy to understand steps that you can take. Two, we've worked with school districts to translate the communications into multiple languages in order to support comprehension among the diverse population that this program serves. translate the communications into multiple languages in order to support comprehension among the diverse population that this program serves. One issue is that at present, families might only think the way to recertify or to verify
将验证所需的步骤精简为三个易于理解的步骤，您可以采取这些步骤。第二，我们与学区合作，将通信翻译成多种语言，以支持该项目服务的不同群体对通信的理解。将通信翻译成多种语言，以支持该项目服务的不同群体对通信的理解。一个问题是，目前，家庭可能只认为重新认证或验证的方式
their information is to send snail mail back to the school district. And instead, there's the opportunity for them to take a picture of their information using their mobile phones and actually email it back. And we simply notified people of the opportunity to go through that process. And then in other instances, we included prepaid envelopes to help ease the process of verifying eligibility. So I'm trying to think about why it is
他们的信息是通过普通邮件寄回学区。相反，他们有机会使用手机拍摄他们的信息并实际通过电子邮件发回。我们只是通知人们有机会经历这个过程。然后，在其他情况下，我们附上了预付费信封，以帮助简化验证资格的过程。所以我想思考为什么
we often have trouble sort of thinking about programs like this because as someone who has been interested in human behavior for a while, it seems to me that programs like these really are, you know, no pun intended, a no-brainer, that this is really something that we should be doing. It seems obvious that we should be doing it. But I think part of the issue is that I think many people might say, if you want to stay in a program that's giving you benefits and these are the steps you need to do in order to get the benefits and you deserve those benefits. Rationally speaking, you should be willing to do those steps in order to get the benefits and I think it fails to take into account the difference between how
我们经常很难去思考这样的项目，因为作为一个对人类行为感兴趣一段时间的人来说，在我看来，这样的项目确实是，双关语，不用动脑子的，这确实是我们在做的事。我们应该做的事情似乎显而易见。但我认为部分问题在于，我认为许多人可能会说，如果你想留在给你福利的项目中，这些是你为了获得福利需要做出的步骤，而你应得这些福利。从理性上讲，你应该愿意为了获得福利而采取这些步骤，我认为这没有考虑到
human beings are supposed to behave as rational creatures and how they actually behave and I feel like that's the central divide that your work is trying to bridge. And I think additionally, you know, the onus is on the government to present information clearly, to present choices clearly, so that people understand what program exists and what their options are and can make the best decisions for themselves and their families. But there's one example that I wanted to point to, which is a phenomenon known as summer melt. This is the phenomenon where talented high school students who are I wanted to point to, which is a phenomenon known as summer melt.
人类本应作为理性生物的表现与他们实际表现之间的差异，我觉得这是你的工作试图弥补的核心分歧。而且我认为，政府有责任清晰地呈现信息，清晰地呈现选择，以便人们了解存在什么程序以及他们的选择是什么，并为自己和家人做出最好的决定。但我想指出一个例子，这就是被称为“暑期流失”的现象。这就是才华横溢的高中生在暑假开始时
This is the phenomenon where talented high school students who are on track to go to college at the start of the summer somehow lose their way and don't show up at college in the fall. Maya and her team have worked on simple, low-cost interventions that can help these students get to college. Their idea, send the students eight text messages over the summer reminding them of impending deadlines. What we found was a 9% increase in college enrollment rates. As a result of eight text messages, I mean that is really profound. Eight text messages is what I send my best friend on any given day.
步入大学正轨，却在夏天不知为何迷失了方向，秋天没有出现在大学里。玛雅和她的团队致力于简单、低成本的干预措施，以帮助这些学生上大学。他们的想法是，在夏天向学生发送八条短信，提醒他们迫在眉睫的截止日期。我们发现大学入学率提高了9%。八条短信的结果，我的意思是这真的很深远。八条短信是我在任何一天发给我最好的朋友的短信。
It seems to me that what you did and what happened to you is actually happens to lots of people all the time where doors close and they feel like it's unbearable that this door is closed because this is where I thought I lived. And then another door opens and you realize there are actually many, many houses in which we can live. I think that's exactly right. And I think one thing that violin, one of the great blessings of playing the violin is that it allowed me to see what it really felt like to be in love with something and to be really
在我看来，你所做的事以及发生在你身上的事实际上经常发生在很多人身上，大门关闭了，他们觉得这扇门关闭是无法忍受的，因为这就是我以为我住的地方。然后另一扇门打开了，你意识到实际上有很多很多的房子我们可以住在里面。我认为这完全正确。我认为有一件事，小提琴，拉小提琴的一大福气是它让我看到了真正爱上某事并真正
passionate about something. And so, if anything, you see sort of features or traits that are extracted in you from engaging with that pursuit. And then your hope is that in the new explorations, those disciplines or those areas can extract those same qualities from you. I'm wondering as you think about your own life, do you feel that your career now has been set? This is the house you're gonna live in forever.
对某事充满热情的感觉。所以，如果有什么不同的话，你会看到通过参与这种追求而在你身上提取的特征或特质。然后你的希望是，在新的探索中，这些学科或这些领域可以从你身上提取出相同的品质。当你想着你自己的生活时，你觉得你现在的职业已经定了下来吗？这是你永远要住的房子。
Do you actually believe, on the other hand, that there might be many other houses you will one day come to live in? Well, certainly never been happier than I am right now working in public service and using my background to help improve people's lives. So I think that that will continue to be a common theme of whatever it is that I end up doing and working in. That said, I think there are so many ways in which that passion can manifest, right? And I think that one thing the past has taught me is that the world has endless opportunities
另一方面，你真的相信有一天你可能会住进许多其他的房子吗？嗯，在公共服务部门工作并用我的背景帮助改善人们的生活，我当然从未比现在更快乐。所以我认为这将继续成为我最终在做和从事的任何事情的共同主题。话虽如此，我认为这种热情可以以很多方式表现出来，对吧？我认为过去教给我的一件事是世界有无限的机会
to positively impact people's lives. And, you know, along the way, I might explore various different paths in order to get there, but as long as I stick to that core value of trying to help people and improve people's lives, I think that there are many ways to do that. And of course you have the cold-called Julia Admeta to aid you. Yeah, so I think that, again, thanks to my mom, I think that there is always that full
对人们的生活产生积极的影响。而且，在此过程中，我可能会探索各种不同的途径来实现这一目标，但只要我坚持试图帮助人们和改善人们生活这一核心价值观，我认为有很多方法可以做到这一点。当然，你还有冷语茱莉亚方法来帮助你。是的，所以我想，再次感谢我妈妈，我认为永远有那种标准冷
proof method of the standard cold-called. That was Maya Shankar. She served as senior advisor for the Social and Behavioral Sciences at the White House Office of Science and Technology Policy on the President Obama. Since then, Maya has left the White House and become Google's first head of behavioral insights. Now, not all of us are going to be great pianists or concert violinists or road scholars or presidential advisors, but I don't think any of those things are the real point of Derek or Maya's story. I think we all have stories in our lives that reflect the fact that the people we are today are not the same people we were a few years ago. We often underestimate our capacity to reinvent ourselves. I was talking some years ago with Rick Potts at the Smithsonian Institution's Human Origins
门电话的万无一失的方法。那是玛雅·尚卡尔。她曾担任奥巴马总统时期白宫科学和技术政策办公室社会与行为科学高级顾问。从那以后，玛雅离开了白宫，成为了谷歌的第一任行为洞察主管。现在，我们并非所有人都能成为伟大的钢琴家、音乐会小提琴手、罗德学者或总统顾问，但我认为这些都不是德里克或玛雅故事的真正重点。我认为我们每个人的人生中都有这样的故事，反映了我们今天的人与几年前的我们不同。我们常常低估了自己重塑自我的能力。几年前，我曾在史密森尼学会的人类起源
program. He's a paleoanthropologist and something he said stuck in my head. He told me that the thing that distinguished early humans from other species was our remarkable capacity to adapt to different conditions. Uniquely, humans live in very cold places, in very hot places, at altitude and sea level. Some of us live long periods underwater or even in outer space. Most of that isn't about our physical abilities, it's really about the mind. There's a lot of truth in that old saying when one door closes, another opens. I want to leave you with a lovely poem by Elizabeth Bishop.
项目与里克·波茨交谈过。他是一位古人类学家，他说的一句话深深印在我的脑海里。他告诉我，早期人类与其他物种的区别在于我们适应不同环境的非凡能力。独特的是，人类生活在非常寒冷的地方、非常炎热的地方、高海拔和海平面。我们中的一些人长期生活在水下甚至太空中。这大部分与我们的身体能力无关，真正与思维有关。那句老话“关上一扇门，就会打开另一扇门”很有道理。我想留给你伊丽莎白·毕晓普的一首可爱的诗。
Singer Amy Mann happened to be at NPR and we asked her to read the poem for us. One art by Elizabeth Bishop. The art of losing isn't hard to master. So many things seem filled with the intent to be lost, that their loss is no disaster. Lose something every day, except the fluster of lost door keys, the hour badly spent, the art of losing isn't hard to master. Then practice losing farther, losing faster, places and names and where it was you meant to travel. None of these will bring disaster.
歌手艾米·曼恰好在NPR，我们请她为我们朗读这首诗。伊丽莎白·毕晓普的《一种艺术》。失去的艺术并不难掌握。许多事情似乎都充满了被遗失的意图，以至于它们的失去并不是灾难。每天失去一些东西，除了丢失钥匙的慌乱，度过糟糕的小时，失去的艺术并不难掌握。然后练习失去得更远，失去得更快，地方、名字以及你打算旅行的地方。这些都不会带来灾难。
I lost my mother's watch. And look, my last or next to last of three loved houses went. The art of losing isn't hard to master. I lost two cities' lovely ones and Vastor, some realms I owned, two rivers, a continent. I missed them, but it wasn't a disaster. Even losing you, the joking voice, a gesture I love. I shant have lied.
我弄丢了我母亲的手表。看，我所珍爱的三座房子中的最后或倒数第二座也消失了。失去的艺术并不难掌握。我失去了两座城市的美丽之物和瓦斯特尔，我拥有的一些领域，两条河流，一个大陆。我想念它们，但这不是一场灾难。甚至失去你，那个开玩笑的声音，我喜爱的姿势。我不会撒谎。
It's evident the art of losing is not too hard to master, though it may look like, write it, like disaster. That was Amy Mann, reading one art by Elizabeth Bishop. Amy was at NPRR to perform with Ted Leo for the All Songs Considered Podcast. This episode was produced by Lucy Perkins, Maggie Penman and Kara McGurk-Allison. NPRR to perform with Ted Leo for the All Songs Considered Podcast. This episode was produced by Lucy Perkins, Maggie Penman and Kara Mugurk Allison. Our team includes Jennifer Schmidt, Parth Shah, Raina Cohen and Renee Clarre. Our supervising producer is Tara Boyle.
很明显，失去的艺术并不算太难掌握，尽管它可能看起来像，写下来，就像一场灾难。那是艾米·曼，朗读伊丽莎白·毕晓普的《一种艺术》。艾米在NPR与泰德·莱奥一起为《所有歌曲沉思》播客表演。本集由露西·帕金斯、玛吉·佩曼和卡拉·麦克格克-艾利森制作。NPR与泰德·莱奥一起为《所有歌曲沉思》播客表演。本集由露西·帕金斯、玛吉·佩曼和卡拉·麦克格克-艾利森制作。我们的团队包括詹妮弗·施密特、帕尔思·沙阿、雷娜·科恩和雷妮·克拉尔。我们的监督制作人是塔拉·博伊尔。
One last thing before we go, we're working on an episode about the revolution that's unfolding before our eyes against sexual harassment. We're thinking about a story that asks, why now? What has changed in the moment to cause so many women to come forward and so many institutions to take a hard look at themselves? If you have a story or a theory you'd like to share with us, record a voice memo and send it to us at HiddenBrain at NPR.org. That's HiddenBrain, one word, at NPR.org. You can also call and leave us a message at 661-772-7246.
在我们离开前最后一件事，我们正在制作一集关于眼前正在展开的反性骚扰革命的节目。我们正在考虑一个故事，它问，为什么是现在？此时此刻发生了什么变化，导致如此多的女性挺身而出，如此多的机构开始认真审视自己？如果您有想与我们分享的故事或理论，请录制语音备忘录并发送至HiddenBrain at NPR.org。那是HiddenBrain，一个词，在NPR.org。您也可以致电并留言661-772-7246。
That's 661-772-Brain. For more HiddenBrain, follow the show on Facebook, Twitter and Instagram and make sure to subscribe to our podcast. brain. of help. Please give it to them. I'm Shankar Vedantam. I hope you have a happy New Year. I'll see you next week. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那是661-772-Brain。想要了解更多HiddenBrain，请在Facebook、Twitter和Instagram上关注该节目，并确保订阅我们的播客。大脑。帮助。请给他们。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。祝您新年快乐。下周见。本集尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。